all right employees about a quarter mile
away I have eyes on several Vehicles
between us
very signal 12.
westbound on uh 92.
turn lane
hey stop Donald Jacobs
3 30 South Massachusetts bailout bailout
cars in the back
let's get into perimeter and hold it for
canine
14 is a possibility he has blue hair all
right guys you need to be behind our
cover goodbye
let's plan on him going south so let's
get some more coverage to the south in
case you break the perimeter
all right everyone's got him he's uh
he's laying down in the woods hey guys
watch these cars coming in here in case
he tries to carjack somebody we don't
want anyone in there
perimeter units when you see people out
walking around tell them to go inside
there's people walking up and down the
street here
okay he's on his hands and knees he's
crawling around the tree
he is moving but he's not standing
I was like he's trying to get away from
us yeah he keeps crawling to the
opposite side of the tree from us
yeah where are you walking right now
25 yards
still laying down behind the tree
he's got cover
15 yards Maybe
okay he's running he's running in the
opposite direction I gotta keep going
keep going canine he's running away from
you
he's running North running Northbound
back towards his car he slowed down he's
in some thick stuff
they said here
he's coming out to the yard he's walking
past the car
just to the uh west of the blue house
hands are up hands are up
walking out to a single Deputy no he's
throwing it out
hands are back up
yeah what's going on
got two deputies out with him
you guys just take your time
lots of people coming to you just take
your time everyone's going to give you
all the air
into custody
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
all right thank you